[Music]
one of the biggest movies of the summer
is opening this week The Lone Ranger
with Johnny Depp and Armie Hammer yeah
and we decided we wanted to find out
more about it so we sent our very own
Andy rector to Santa Fe New Mexico for
the Lone Ranger press junket to meet the
stars of the film how did it go Andy get
on okay well did you get to meet all the
stars we did the best we could let me
just say all right I'm assuming this is
excellent let's take a look
[Music]
hi I'm outside of Santa Fe New Mexico
for the big Walt Disney Pictures Lone
Ranger press junket we got here a little
late they didn't have any slots for us
so apparently I just found out I won't
be interviewing Johnny Depp I won't be
interviewing Armie Hammer they said
there's one star of the movie I could
interview though and I guess we'll see
how it goes I'm here speaking to one of
the stars The Lone Ranger
hello silver so according to my notes
you've done a lot of film and television
work care to comment on how any of that
stuff compares to your work on The Lone
Ranger
so you're 11 years old is it tough to
work in Hollywood when you're so young
and you know you're worried that you
know you're gonna Lindsay Lohan at some
point
who's a bigger jerk Johnny Depp or Armie
Hammer they're good look I'm sorry this
isn't working for me I mean I came all
the way to New Mexico to interview the
stars of the movie and I can't get
access to anybody and I I got you and I
mean you're great believe me you're
great and I don't know I just
this isn't what I thought this would be
you know what after this I'm Don Dee how
was your day you want it you want to
hang out Oh calm down you're next
[Music]
you know this has been an amazing day I
did not think that this was gonna work
out for me at all I thought it was gonna
have a lousy time and I mean little did
I know that I would end up making a new
friend where are you going wait come
back
well that's Hollywood for you a bunch of
phonies all right back to you Conan this
is Andy Richter reporting from the lone
ranger junket New Mexico
[Music]
[Applause]
nice job but I'm really mad that we
didn't get a shot of him driving away
from a really nice car sounds like a
really a sportscar